il a buzzé team celle ci au jc faire des
grands bonsoir bonsoir alors hélène ça
commence et tahoua vendredi midi la
santé publique du canada dit nous on
n'aime pas beaucoup le les
rassemblements de 20 personnes qu'on
entend annoncer au québec on demande aux
provinces être plus prudente le
aujourd'hui en art mais on dit le micron
compte tenu qu'en ontario va devenir le
variant dominante si quelques jours
j'exagère à peine et que ça risque de se
produire partout au pays soyez prudents
et la troisième dont j'ai une bonne idée
alors qu'est-ce que vous décoder danser
message qu'on envoie hélène
d'ottawa mais écoutez ce n'est pas la
première fois qu à ottawa
qui a pas de contrôle sur un cloud aucun
système de santé il faut quand même le
dire qu'on envoie des messages parfois
beaucoup plus
prudent plus strictes peut-être par
rapport à la santé publique que on en
reçoit au niveau des provinces qui l ont
à gérer les attentes de la population
alors en soit ce n'est pas une première
fois mais on sent effectivement qu'il ya
un certain malaise face à québec et on
en a discuté dans le passé à patrice le
fameux vin de monsieur legault est celle
de monsieur harouna en fait était-il
dictée par monsieur legault alors on
sent qu'il ya un malaise mais ce n'est
quand même pas la juridiction d'ottawa
de dire aux provinces ont à faire on se
rappelle de l'alberta par exemple mais
toute la question d'un troisième dont
évidemment ça relance l'enjeu de
l'équité mondiale ce gain marginal que
l'on fera avec une troisième dose au
canada et qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
obtenir à la place on administrait ces
vaccins en première dose ailleurs dans
le monde pour éviter l'apparition d'un
nouveau variance il ya peut-être une
question beaucoup plus grande équité
mondial qui se pose davantage ici est
une très bonne question que vous posez
d'ailleurs à michel s'est logée sur la
com dit hélène c'est un on a vu cette
cet équilibre là jouer là cette danse là
depuis le début ta voix des fois ci se
montrent plus prudents que certaines
provinces quel ministre dans la vraie
vie les choses qu'est ce que vous voyez
le même processus là
je vois même processus joie aussi que le
verrez un micron et semble plus
dangereux qu'on le disait au début plus
contagieux à tous qu'on voit ce qui se
passe au royaume uni on a littéralement
à confiner et peut-être qu'on a décidé
un peu trop vite au québec de la limite
de 20 personnes et
publié ça a été ça nous a surpris
c'était bien c'était pas la conférence
de presse était prévue cette nuit que
cette ville a été annoncé ça devait être
quelques jours plus tard peut-être qu'on
aurait changé un peu d'idée si on avait
attendu quelques jours et mois j'exclus
pas qu'on revienne sur certaines de ces
décisions là parce que ça semble
effectivement c'est sérieux et
la santé publique d'ottawa rebond nos
pages de gérer le système de simplice
c'est quand même des experts de santé
publique votre connu moi je serais très
léger je serais très intéressé à savoir
aujourd'hui parce que pense à ça du
public du québec - stéphanie mais
j'espère qu'on va pour un jouet dans le
même film que la noël l'an dernier où on
s'est retrouvé en janvier avec avec un
couvre feu avec avec des cas qui a
augmenté beaucoup c'est vrai à la
décharge du gouvernement du québec
c'était pas évident l'on navigué avec
beaucoup d'inconnues pour prendre une
décision pour le temps des fêtes
par contre une chose qu'on savait
absolument sans aucune ambiguïté c'est
que noël c'est 25 décembre et puis
pourtant ça ça fait longtemps qu'on le
sait mais il ya toujours pas de tests
rapides à la disposition de tous les
québécois comme on ouvre on aurait aimé
les avoir parce que ce soit évidemment
l'a31 donc on peut en discuter la
question est intéressante mais il est
trop tard pour une réelle par contre des
tests rapides ça pourrait vraiment être
utile ça pourrait permettre aux gens de
le tester et puis de d'éviter de
contaminer des la famille et des amis
avant une réunion
cette semaine monsieur paré maudit la
semaine dernière ici j'ai des bonnes
nouvelles la semaine prochaine sur les
de la distribution des tests rapides
pour toute la population avait-il dit à
suivre demain une conférence de presse à
13h
armée tour de table là dessus les
excuses à mes fans et la minus qui est
assez pro active depuis qu'elle est en
poste à perd pas beaucoup de temps
non non on l'avait vu c'est elle qui
était la grande architecte de la
livraison des vaccins cracovie d'une
très grande efficacité on en doutait au
début mais ça a fonctionné on semble
constater que madame annan veut mettre
cette efficacité au service de la
question des militaires qui ont fait
l'objet de
deux
inadéquat sexuel voilà exactement et que
les excuses d'aujourd'hui était pour le
dire assez et manqué un peu de passion à
trois personnes devant des caméras on
n'a pas besoin de 40 minutes c'est ça
manquait de dorment un petit peu ça par
rapport à d'autres excuses qu'on a vu
dans le passé évidemment le contexte y
est pour beaucoup mais la grande
question c'est si madame à nantes va
réussir à faire sa promesse à savoir de
transférer toutes les accusations qui
sont faites des tribunaux militaires
vers les tribunaux civils elle nous
disait aujourd'hui que c'est quelque
chose qu'elle espère faire très
rapidement elle nous a parlé d' en début
d'année ça dépend c'est quoi votre
définition du début de l'année mais ça
fait quand même un mois on attend encore
et c'est ça le vrai test de madame annan
quant à l'efficacité tout ça très bien
mais chercher ses fans et la tue
rapidement
ça ne m'affole j'ai nommé les deux
on est trop imprécis mais non je pense
que c'est une bonne nouvelle
dès sa nomination elle a été très très
rapide donc tant mieux parce que ça fait
depuis 2015 que qu'on sait qu'il faut
prendre des mesures depuis le temps où
la juge deschamps avait remis son
rapport puis les recommandations phares
d'être implanté et s'insurgent parce que
dans la et en ce moment là on a un gros
problème de recrutement qu'on peut
comprendre que c'est pas très longtemps
pour une femme en ce moment de dire
tiges pour faire carrière dans l'armée
on manque de bras la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre est réel ils ont besoin
d'engager parce que 7000 personnes ils
vont avoir de la difficulté à respecter
l'idée d'avoir l'objectif d'avoir le
corps de leur dollar effectif qui sont
des femmes ces cinq ans de pause
produits donc oui il faut il faut donner
un peu voir sur une aire une amie
question michel
j'aurais voulu voir monsieur trudeau
s'excuser aussi je comprends qu'on va
dire il s'excuse de trop d'affaires puis
s'était pas
confiance après
oui mais papa dada les cérémonies comme
tel et c'est quand même lui qui a dormi
là encore des chats dans son bureau
pendant des années ça et ça reste à
faire moi j'avais j'aurais rendu chaud
plus solennelle et plus officielle avec
le premier ministre à cet endroit là
plutôt que juste stabilisé la défense
bien que madame madame anna fait
toujours faire ce qu'il fallait faire
très bien loi 21 avec le cas de chelsea
cette enseignante qui a été engagé par
la commission scolaire malgré la loi 21
avec un voile et elle a été mutée à
d'autres fonctions ça percolé depuis
quoi jeudi dans l'opinion publique il ya
eu des reportages hélène puis au canada
anglais ça beaucoup perco les jeudi
vendredi samedi puis ça dépend internés
juifs entendre ben ici aussi au canada
qui
souffre entendre monsieur trudeau et
monsieur legault là dessus aujourd'hui
suis en désaccord profond
avec le projet de loi 21 je ne trouve
pas que dans une société libre et
ouverte quelqu'un devrait perdre sa job
à cause de sa religion et et de porc
donnez-le excuses au gouvernement du
québec que c'est l'ingérence fédérale
mais de simplement dire non des
québécois sont en désaccord avec ce
principe
quand on regarde la peau les doigts 21
ils étaient appuyés par deux parties la
cac et le parti québécois qui représente
plus que la moitié des québécois les
sondages montrent qu'une majorité de
québécois qui sont d'accord c'est une
loi qui est raisonnable et je te content
quand même de voir dans la réaction de
justin trudeau au début qui disait mais
le sto québécois à
débattre de cette eau alors entre eux
bon évidemment c'est pas une surprise
michel 5e monsieur trudeau reste contre
cette loi là en même temps il intex
traitement prudent il n'y a pas envie de
rouvrir tout ça maintenant façon la loi
est contestée il rajoute encore
suprêmement
la loi est contesté et au lever ou de la
clause dérogatoire qui utilisait deux
fois contre l'achat à l'endroit de la
charte québécoise on a droit de la
charte fédérale donc abandonné au silex
à nice il ya peu de chances que ce sera
très loin mais ma cour suprême même si
le gouvernement fédéral intervienne
mais moi ce que je note c'est que ça
fait 2 2 500 yuans a été adoptée monde
est aux premiers cols ça m'a fait
beaucoup penser à ce que le rapport
bouchard taylor avait dit brodeur depuis
l'actrice donne
encore deux
maintenant qu'on a eu beaucoup beaucoup
d'énergie politique là dessus pour un
core 2 vous êtes on a réglé un problème
qui n'hésitait pas à se sortir puis
n'est pas très élevé qui n'est pas très
important de toute évidence stéphanie
numérique m
oui c'est ça mais je pense que ça a été
payant pour
le réussit à
associer la loi 21 à la seule forme de
laïcité possible comme si on est contre
la loi 21 alors on est contre elle à
hong hong et contre lui on est content
la nation québécoise et puis là-bas sa
place monsieur trudeau dans une
situation difficile ou pique envers
contester la loi 21 ça fait 4 degrés
comme quelqu'un qui qui compte la
laïcité alors que c'est paule ka et
comme michel le disait où il n'y avait
pas nécessairement de problème au québec
dans les écoles si on s'en était tenu à
appliquer comme là mission chanter leur
le suggérer l'interdiction de signes
religieux aux vraiment aux gens qui sont
des représentants de la force coercitive
donc les policiers les juges mais on
aurait pas eu tous ces ennuis na et on
n'avait pas vu un ce matin
encore probablement mais bon que voulez
vous on en est là que s'est pas terminée
parce que la clause dérogatoire
évidemment tous les temps il faut les
renouveler donc on va en parler encore
longtemps hélène
mais j'avoue que je pas d'accord avec
mes deux collègues sur la qualification
du nombre parce que bon évidemment c'est
cette personne moi qui étais tu as c'est
parce qu'elle est embauché par la suite
mais il faut savoir aussi que cette voix
21 âprement aussi empêché l'embauchent
de beaucoup d'autres personnes alors le
nombre est vraiment beaucoup plus adroit
qui
oui il ya le droit acquis mais après les
autres embauches qui n'ont peut-être pas
eu lieu aussi cette dame elle représente
aussi toutes les autres qui n'ont pas
été embauchés on le voit moins aimé ça
et ça existe aussi au championnat 6 on
le saura jamais je pense que tout ça ils
le sont aussi deux visions radicalement
différentes sur wii cette notion de
laïcité c'est que beaucoup j'allais dire
le canada anglais mais c'est pas
nécessairement juste au canada anglais
c'est une fusion de certaines visions du
multiculturalisme ou la religion n'est
pas considéré comme une idée elle est
considérée comme une identité et dès
lors qu'on tombe dans cette adéquation
là et bien on peut pas comprendre que
quelqu'un se fasse passer pour son
identité alors qu'aujourd'hui monsieur
legault qui elle est l'exemple qui le
donnait il a parlé d'un chandail sur
lequel on dirait je pense que votre
parti libéral ou quelque chose comme ça
il fait référence ici à mener et des
politiques et ça personne ne remet en
question que les idées peuvent parfois
être obligés d'être mises en sourdine
d'ailleurs au gouvernement fédéral ont
eu des codes par exemple une séparatiste
qui avait été congédié du gouvernement
fédéral savait une colère parce que les
gens qui portent la prison sous l'ère
landes que ça fait partie de leur
identité qui dont on peut dire que c'est
pas vrai là bas et c'est un débat
c'est de l'auto détermination peut-être
j'imagine mais mais il est lol la
confrontation fondamental c'est que d'un
côté on dit c'est qu'une idée est une
idée peut être mise de côté huit heures
par jour et les indices banon c'est mon
identité et je suis ce que je suis 24
heures sur 24 ça mais michel et ça nous
a pas frappés là puisque monsieur
trudeau a été clair y est qu'on essaye
était convaincant comme les gens qui
bien que son congrès ce camp mais ça
vous a pas frappé là la prudence signal
qu'envoie yake bac 5 j'ai pas envie
d'une joute politique là dessus dessous
est la
non puis de toute façon la cause sa voix
devant les tribunaux il peut s'il le
veut à pully une des contestations
juridiques mais ça veut pas dire d'abord
que les juges une seconde vie à la cour
suprême parle toujours du même côté
c'était dingue à monsieur duplessis
aujourd'hui lui arrive bien plus souvent
qu'autrement de dire qu'il trouvait
ça c'est une chose deuxièmement à la
fait se noie provincial et c'est pas de
sortie
on ne sait pas pourquoi la commission
scolaire engagée cette enseignante ça
d'abord est ce qu'on sait si la
commission scolaire savait qu'elle
portait le voile ce qu'on sait c'est
moi j'ai parlé j'ai parlé au président
de la commission scolaire je me suis
fait plus autre exemple mais qui me
disait qu'on était tellement dans une
pénurie de main d'oeuvre que des fois
les entrevues d'embauché faisait au
téléphone mais en même temps même si on
n'a pas vu la personne on connaît la loi
on est supposé de réitérer la loi le
second lorsqu'à la personne se présente
alors c'est un argument un petit peu
donc lhi gilles mais dont les deux camps
se regardent
stéphanie puis en corse et les mêmes
arguments qu'on entende d'un côté comme
de l'eau protection des droits
individuels les gens disent y'a la
charte plomb devrait pas enlever un
droit de porter un quelque chose qu'on
considérait dans notre identité là bas
effectivement fait l'accueil a rien de
neuf sous le soleil alors que là on a
vraiment la possibilité de mettre un
visage sur la loi 21 dont jusqu'ici sa
demeure est peut-être un débat théorique
maintenant on a un exemple concret de ce
que ça donne et
ce après ça prend une nouvelle dimension
mais oui effectivement sinon le reste
les choses suivent leur cours il ya eu
une première décision qui a été rendue
au québec par la cour supérieure et puis
on le jeudi que c'était une utilisation
désinvolte et
inconsidéré de la clause dérogatoire il
ne dit que ça viol est effectivement la
charte canadienne et la charte
québécoise le dis aussi que cela violait
les lois internationales donc là la
déclaration des droits de l'homme
insistait à en faire un stade couvert
c'est une invitation à faire appel à la
justice internationale
selon jean foucher tout seul est dit
plus haut les peaux fini puis on
continuera d'emprunter ou pas du tout
peur à moi et puis le grande qu'avec a
fait appel de cette décision conçu
période donc et c'est
le dernier panel nature hélène chance et
fanny 20 secondes chacun d'eux on
s'attend à quoi hélène mise à jour
économique
ce fameux 40 milliards de dollars pour
les autochtones les enfants autochtones
c'est quand même très intéressant c'est
une compensation
gargantuesque la moitié de cette somme
20 milliards iraient pour dédommager
pour le passé
j'espère qu'il y aura un débat là-dessus
parce que quand on voit ces jours ci les
orphelins du plessis nous rappeler
qu'ils n'ont eu qu'une que 25000 dollars
mais peut-être qu'il ya lieu de
s'interroger sont des montants accordés
dans ce cas-ci solution va reparler
michel
cher de voir ce que le gouvernement va
peur sur l'inflation ce qu'on va en
parler vrai beurre dans cette mise à
jour économique parce que c'est ça qui
fait peur aux citoyens que stéphanie
avoue vincent l'inflation même chose 1
7% aux etats-unis la semaine dernière ça
s'est jamais vu en 40 ans en espérant
qu'un gouvernement pour trouver une
façon de s'attaquer à ces années sans
lui de d'intervenir plus tôt qu'à la
banque du canada mais de poêle ajouter
d'huile sur le feu avec de nouvelles
mesures ce serait déjà
très bien je repars très bientôt merci
bonne soirée d'adieu au revoir merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit